[Musique]
cinq mois après le début de l'année on
aurait épuisé l'ensemble des ressources
renouvelables que la planète est capable
de fournir en une année
donc on voit bien qu'on a un souci en
terme de consommation en france
notamment et en termes d'empreinte
écologique en particulier
cette empreinte écologique en france
elle est principalement dû encore une
fois aux émissions de gaz à effet de
serre le premier poste d'émission de gaz
à effet de serre restant le transport en
france
consommer moins de viande c'est aussi un
moyen relativement efficace de faire
diminuer cette empreinte écologique -
bétonner la france est une des
championnes d'europe voire du monde en
matière d'artificialisation des terres
[Musique]
la mongolie c'est un peu particulier
parce que c'est un c'est un pays dans
lequel les habitants
d'une part ce ne se chauffe au charbon
mais c'est aussi un pays assez
particulier puisque le régime
alimentaire en mongolie est extrêmement
carnet dont comporte énormément de
viande et cette viande des produits dans
les steppes mongoles
il faut énormément d espace pour nourrir
ses animaux donc ça signifie que si tout
le monde vivait comme un mongol
il nous faudrait plusieurs planètes pour
pouvoir tout simplement faire paître des
des moutons pour pouvoir nous nourrir
[Musique]
la suède a encore une empreinte carbone
en relativement assez élevé par habitant
de par les déplacements de ces
populations de part aussi la production
d'électricité donc à une forte
proportion de renouvelables en suède
certes mais derrière on a aussi beaucoup
de centrales thermiques qui tourne pour
pouvoir générer le reste de
l'électricité
et puis c'est aussi un pays qui coupent
beaucoup de forêts qui produit beaucoup
de papier qui produit beaucoup de bois
donc qui a une empreinte forestia élevé
aussi très élevée aussi
[Musique]
on dirait presque dans les limites d'une
seule planète ça s'explique par le fait
que en équateur on a des politiques
notamment des politiques alimentaires
des politiques énergétiques basés sur
les renouvelables basée sur un régime
relativement peu carnet donc l'équateur
est un exemple intéressant ils ont banni
les pesticides par exemple certains
types de pesticides la déforestation a
été freinée de manière drastique aussi
en équateur donc ça peut être un exemple
à suivre sans être un pays sous
développés où on a une malnutrition
rampante et on a d'énormes problèmes
[Musique]
oh
en un mois un mois et demi le qatar a
quasiment épuisé l'ensemble des
ressources si tout le monde vivait comme
comme comme un qatari
ça s'explique en grande partie par les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
extrêmement élevé par personne des
habitants du qatar puisque c'est un pays
où on peut pas vivre sans clim que
l'ensemble de l'électricité est produite
à partir de ressources fossiles que
c'est un pays qui importe absolument
tout de l'extérieur puisque
l'agriculture est quasiment inexistante
avec des modes de consommation qui sont
extrêmement dispendieux aussi avec
beaucoup de gaspillage avec beaucoup de
consommation de viande
donc tout ça quand on quand on
effectivement quand on additionne ça
fait que on a on a un mode de vie qui
génère une empreinte écologique
extrêmement élevé
[Musique]
ce qui explique cette ce constat un peu
un peu alarmant c'est que les américains
ont une énorme empreinte carbone liée
d'une part à leurs déplacements ils
utilisent énormément la voiture les
transports en commun sont quasi
inexistants et puis les américains aussi
consomme énormément tous produits
confondus c'est parmi les premiers
consommateurs de viande au monde
ils gaspillent aussi énormément près de
50 % de la nourriture aux états unis est
gaspillée donc et jetés avant de pouvoir
être consommée donc tout ça mis bout à
bout explique que voilà il nous faudrait
il nous faudrait cinq planètes pour
pouvoir vivre comme pour que tout le
monde puisse vivre comme des américains